Democrats target the Trump
administration over the census Mike
Pence comes under fire for opposing gay
flags flying over the American Embassy
in Botswana and Bernie tries to
reinvigorate his flagging campaign I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
man a lot to get to today plus breaking
news out of Iran where the Iranian
regime continues to be extraordinarily
militant this time they have fired on
two oil tankers in the Straits of Hormuz
so tensions are ratcheting up we'll get
to all of that in just a second first if
you follow the news every day and this
makes you think God maybe I'm going to
die one day because news is just
terrible well then probably while you're
thinking about death you may as well
make the best of it go over to policy
genius and go check out life insurance
now if you've been procrastinating on
this thing usually that's bad news but
your procrastination has now worked in
your favor because well you are
procrastinating on life insurance policy
genius is putting together a great way
for you to get policy genius now is the
time for procrastinating to stop policy
genius is the easy way to shop for
insurance online in just two minutes you
can compare quotes from top insurers and
find your best price once you apply the
policy genius team will handle all the
paperwork and the red tape no sales
pressure no hidden fees just financial
protection and peace of mind policy
genius doesn't just make life insurance
easy they can also help you find the
right home insurance auto insurance
disability insurance so if you need life
insurance oh you've been busy doing
literally anything else
check out policy genius it's the easy
way to compare all the top insurers and
find the best about value for you policy
genius com nobody wants to shop for life
insurance nobody wants to think about
death but now that you're thinking about
death cuz I just put it in your head you
should go shop for life insurance go
check them out at policy genius com they
made it really easy for you that's
policy genius calm all right well the
breaking news this morning is that the
Iranian government has now attacked two
oil tankers according to the New York
Times two oil tankers came under attack
on Thursday in the Gulf of Oman forcing
their crews to abandon ship and sending
at least one vessel ablaze a month after
four tankers were damaged in the same
waterway a vital thoroughfare for much
of the world's oil products the
early-morning attacks escalated tensions
in an re tense region where Ron had long
been at odds with Saudi Arabia and the
United Arab Emirates and they are
backing opposite sides in the civil war
in Yemen the Houthis backed by the
Iranians whose slogan is death to the
Jews
death to Israel death to America really
nice folks those are the folks are
fighting on behalf of Iran the Saudis of
course have their own set of problems
and they are at war in Yemen relations
between the United States allied with
the UAE and Saudi Arabia and Iran have
also worsened frictions have become so
intense other nations have pled with all
sides to stay calm
rather than provoke an all-out war which
is really kind of pathetic because the
reality is the United States is not
interested in war on no one in the
United States is up for a conflict with
Iran but if they keep firing on our
ships I'm not sure exactly what we are
supposed to do other than ratchet up
economic tension at a certain point if
they fire on too many of our ships we're
not going to have a choice we're going
to have to eviscerate the regime but up
to that point nobody is really
interested in that the Trump
administration clearly is not interested
in that
on Wednesday Prime Minister Shinzo Abe a
of Japan who is visiting Iran and trying
to bridge the gap between Iran in the
United States warned of the risk of
stumbling into military conflict well
you know what heightens that risk
Iran firing on American ships that's one
of those things that might heighten the
possibility of a conflict last month
Jeremy Hunt the British Foreign
Secretary said we're very worried about
the risk of a conflict happening by
accident with an escalation that is
unintended on either side this is
everybody sort of whistling past the the
graveyard with regard to Iran the
Iranian regime is deliberately
attempting to provoke military action by
the United States that is limited in
scope limited enough that it doesn't
actually take down the regime but but
far enough that it unifies the Iranian
people behind a very unpopular regime
there have been rolling economic
protests across Iran for years at a time
and since 2009 there's been a broiling
seething undercurrent of anti-government
activity in Iran the Obama
administration committed a great act of
evil by funding the Iranian government
and undercutting that undercurrent of
resistance to an evil regime they
decided instead they're going to work
with that evil regime strengthen that
evil regime hand them pallets of cash
open up their economy give them all
sorts of access to world markets and
money that was a horrible horrible move
the Trump administration has done the
reverse and so now Iran is basically
trying to do the same thing that North
Korea has done for years act so militant
that everybody sort of backs down and
says you know just give me some money
will you leave us alone
it was not immediately clear how the
most recent attacks were carried out or
by whom just as the circumstances of
last month's attacks from a murky well
the circumstances last month don't
actually remain all that murky everybody
sort of understands the Iranian
government was behind it the two ships
that were struck on Thursday appeared to
be more seriously damaged than those hit
in May on a visit to the UAE about two
weeks ago John Bolton president Trump's
national security adviser said without
disclosing any evidence that Iran was
almost certainly responsible for the
attacks in May which Iranian officials
denied which of course they would do
Boulton said who else do you think is
doing it which is the correct question
other American officials said Iran's
regional and Iran's regional adversaries
have been more cautious about publicly
assigning blame that's because they wish
to avoid conflict I think more than
Bolton they want to emirati officials
describe the attacks of state-sponsored
but did not specify a state well it
wasn't Israel mr. Trump has repudiated
the 2015 deal limiting Iran's nuclear
program he recently moved to cut off
Iran's remaining oil exports and sends
additional military forces to the region
just yesterday President Trump spoke
about the German government's
willingness to take Iranian oil and
blasted former German officials like the
former Chancellor of Germany Gerhard
schröder who is basically acted as an
Iranian oil interest in Germany trying
to funnel Iranian oil into Germany Iran
recently threatened to block the Strait
of Hormuz which controls something it's
a choke point for something like 80 to
90 percent of all oil supply on planet
earth it's it's a really key choke point
the Houthi faction in Yemen backed by
Iran has launched attacks recently on
targets in Saudi Arabia including oil
pipelines fueling fears of a wider
conflict now this should go to show you
by the way
all of this should go to show you that
there has been this lie in American
foreign policy for years promulgated by
folks who dislike Israel in the State
Department that at the very center of
all Middle Eastern conflicts lies the
State of Israel and its existence that
if you just solved the
israel-palestinian issue then all other
conflicts in the region would disappear
weird because every major war in the
region effectively speaking has not
involved Israel at least since 1973
every major war in the region has
involved States attacking each other the
iran-iraq war the Iraqi invasion of
Saudi Arabia the American invasion of
Iraq and now the war in Yemen the war in
Syria all of these involve internecine
warfare inside the Muslim world they
have nothing to do with Israel so this
notion that we have to solve the
israeli-palestinian conflict in order to
calm the region it's just a bunch of
crap and it always was a bunch of crap
and that's being proved on a daily basis
in the Middle East and that is a side
point but it's worthy of note because no
matter who the next Democrat in office
is they will immediately swivel back to
the lie that at the center of all
conflict lies the jewels much of the
world's oil and gas comes from the
Persian Gulf area bordered by energy
powerhouses like Saudi Arabia the UAE
Iran Iraq Kuwait and Bahrain some of it
leaves
the region through pipelines a
significant portion is carried by ships
that must pass through the Strait of
Hormuz and the Gulf of Oman oil prices
rose more than three percent on world
markets in the hours after the attacks
on Thursday Shinzo Abe ate the head of
Japan he met Wednesday with president
Hassan rouhani of Iran and Thursday with
Ayatollah Ali Khamenei the supreme
leader who's actually in charge he
delivered a note from mr. Trump to
Khomeini but the Ayatollah rebuffed the
overture said he could not expect honest
negotiation from the American
administration because when I think
honest ago she ation I think the Iranian
government which has lied at every step
along the way about its desire to
develop nuclear weapons Khomeini said I
do not see Trump as worthy of any
message exchange I do not have any reply
for him now or in the future basically
the Iranians are hoping and praying that
Trump is ejected from office in 2020 and
then they will be dealing with a much
warmer president Buddha judge or
President Biden or President Kamala
Harris or President Elizabeth Warren
Iranian officials suggested that Ankara
attacks were meant to prevent friendly
dialogue and provoke aggression so
they're trying to claim that the United
States basically bombed ships that were
associated with the United States that's
what they're trying to shore sure javad
zarif the foreign minister said
suspicious doesn't begin to describe
what likely transpired this morning yes
I'm sure that's what happened I'm sure
that the West is trying to provoke a war
with Iran this is the lie that Iran has
been telling for years which is that we
want to go to war with them hey little
note to Iran if the United States
desperately wanted to go to war with
Iran the government would no longer
exist it would be a pile of rubble the
fact is that Iran could do damage to the
United States because there are terror
cells associated with and funded by Iran
all over planet earth it is true that a
war with Iran would be more protracted
than a war with Iraq only because the
Iranian Revolutionary Guard Corps is
extraordinarily large and paid off by
the government however would the regime
in Iran survive a direct conflict with
the United States no the regime in Iran
would not survive a direct conflict with
the United States which is why they are
attempting these sort of mosquito bites
directed at the United States hoping
that the United States will then knock a
couple of Iranian ships out of the water
for example and then the Iranians can
stump around the Iranian government can
stump around talking about how they need
to defend their country side with the
ayatollahs and they're looking for a
rally around the flag effect that's the
entire purpose of this particular move
because the fact is that the Iranian
government is out of money
the choking of the Iranian economy which
has happened under the Trump
administration and for which they
deserve full credit has had significant
effects on the Iranian government they
are feeling it all across the country
they're not able to fund their terrorist
friends at come us in the Gaza Strip
anymore very very sad all of their
regional ambitions are being gradually
thwarted by the fact that they are
running out of cash and so they're are
attempting to lash out in the hopes that
this will create an impetus for
everybody to basically pay them off
American analysts were poring over
imagery as well as signal intercepts on
Thursday to help determine how the
attack happened and who was responsible
according to a senior American official
based on the extent of the damage to the
tankers early indications suggested that
either minds or torpedoes were used said
the senior official who acknowledged the
investigation was still in its early
stages
last week General Frank McCann Mackenzie
who's the head of US Central Command
told reporters traveling with him in the
Middle East he believed the Iranians or
their proxies could carry out an attack
in any moment he said I think the threat
is imminent and you remember that there
was a British general who had disagreed
and then the British Foreign Secretary
said uh yeah he's wrong the Iranians are
getting really really militant one of
the ships struck on Thursday is the
front Saltaire owned by the Norwegian
shipping company front line it was
burned its crew had evacuated the vessel
CPC corporation is a Taiwanese oil
company that had chartered the ship to
carry naphtha which is a petroleum
product and confirmed that had been
attacked the Norwegian newspaper VG
quoted a frontline spokesman as saying
that its ship was on fire that all 23
members had been rescued the other
tanker was the Panamanian flag
kakuka courageous it was carrying
methanol and the Iranian state news
media reported that it too was on fire
it eventually ended up finding a port in
it was reportedly headed from the Saudi
port of all jubail to Singapore both the
ship's owner and its operator said all
21 crew members had abandoned ship were
later rescued by a nearby vessel so if I
mentioned earlier these were American
flag they were not American flag they
were foreign flag but these are all
allies of the United States obviously
Iran's state news media confirmed the
attacks on the two tankers and the
rescue of 44 Mariners the news channel
IRI nn said a rescue team from the
southern Iranian province of horrors gan
had picked up the crew of the ship
carrying the Panamanian flag Japan's
trade ministry said both ships were
carrying Japan related cargo so we'll
bring you the latest on that I will
point out in one second how insane the
coverage of these sorts of incidents are
how preconceived narratives about the
evils of the Trump administration really
shape the coverage in an extraordinarily
significant way first I got to talk to
you about a topic that I love sports so
I don't know if you been watching the
NBA Finals it is fantastic this year
although the injuries to Kevin Durant
I mean it's devastating obviously I love
sports whether we are talking about
tennis or whether you were talking about
basketball or my favorite sport baseball
well let me tell you about another great
podcast that I told you about a few
months ago it's called Sports Wars from
wandering it's all about the greatest
sports rivalries of all time their
stories the action might not know
they've done episodes on Green Bay
teammates Brett Favre versus Aaron
Rodgers who ended up taking his job
Rafael Nadal versus Roger Federer
battling it out for the title of
greatest tennis player of all time they
recently had a match at the French Open
Nate all won again he has a lifetime
winning record against Roger Federer and
if he wins another major it's going to
be fascinating to see where he lists on
sort of the final ranking now they're
doing a series on former NBA stars
Isaiah Thomas versus Michael Jordan
which is an amazing story basically
Michael Jordan militated to keep Isiah
Thomas off the dream team off the 1992
Dream Team because he hated Isiah Thomas
so much there was serious bad blood
between those two it's a surprising
story and a really fascinating story so
go subscribe listen to sports Wars on
Apple podcast Spotify or wherever you're
listening right now just go subscribe
and download at Sports Wars really fun
to listen to I love the podcast it's
great sports Wars on the Apple podcast
go check it out when you need a break
from the news listen to something
entertaining and and I think really
interesting check it out Sports Wars
okay so Liz sly is the Washington Post
Beirut bureau chief and here is what she
tweeted out in the aftermath of this big
escalation in the Persian Gulf to oil
tankers struck and on fire in the Strait
of Hormuz focus of us our intentions
comes after Trump failed to heed the
last tanker warning and imposed more
sanctions okay that last sentence is so
astonishing it beggars description comes
after Trump failed to heed the last tank
rewarding and imposed more sanction so
in other words if the Iranian government
a terrorist a terrorist backing evil
repressive disgusting regime bombs a
couple of tankers and then threatens the
largest military force the most powerful
military force in the history of mankind
and that most powerful military
in the history of mankind led by the
presidents of the United States the
commander-in-chief refuses to kowtow to
a a third-rate power that represses its
own people in jails dissonance then it's
his fault it's president Trump's fault
if the Iranians get more militant
there's this soft bigotry of low
expectations that the media have with
regard to the ruling of Muslim states in
particular that is really pathetic it's
really pathetic can you imagine if the
UK France even Russia were to be bombing
tankers that were that were allied with
the United States in its wreak slap at
the United States would there be these
sorts of headlines do you think there
would be these sorts of headlines about
you know this is all because the United
States has just been so provocative
toward these countries been so
provocative toward Russia know it be
why isn't Trump being more militant with
Russia why isn't Trump doing something
about right must be he's a Russian
stooge guys but Barack Obama who
actually acted as an Iranian stooge who
spent years lying blatantly to the faces
of the American people lying in their
face Ben Rhodes his national security
adviser openly acknowledged that his
involvement in the administration
involved crafting a narrative I eat
lying to the American people that the
Iranian regime was about to moderate and
if the United States made some sort of
payoff deal then Iran would become a
moderate stable force for good in the
region it was all a lie they knew it was
a lie at the time and they pushed it
they pushed that lie the Obama
administration counted dictators on a
regular basis it was Barack Obama
pledging flexibility on an open mic to
the Russian government in the middle of
the 2012 election was he ever hit with
headlines like this from the Washington
Post bureau chief in Beirut of course
not it's that President Trump refuses to
kowtow to the Iranian government that's
a big problem and as I say there is this
tendency on the part of the media to
treat terrorist activity by Muslim
governments as though it is not
terrorist activity at all so in the
Palestinian Authority engages in the
paying of terrorists when Hamas engages
in rocket fire on a democratic ally of
the United States when the Iranian
government engages in the spread of
terror across planet earth then it's all
about well I guess the West must have
provoked them those are the West must
have done something bad this Springs
from a peculiar and ugly perspective on
American foreign policy and really the
world that suggests that there is a
power higher
our key that dictates morality in other
words that if you are more powerful
you must have victimized somebody at the
bottom of the scale and so the people at
the bottom of the scale should feel
fully liberated to be as evil as they
want to be Iran is put upon by the West
and therefore if they bomb random ships
well you know that's just what they do
guys and you got to give him some room
to express themselves what you expect
the President of the United States to
bow before the whims of dictators who
literally lead chance
death to Israel death to America that's
what you want Washington bureau chief
from Beirut how pathetic
okay now speaking of pathetic yesterday
the Democrats decided to hold the
Commerce Secretary and the AG the
Attorney General in contempt at least in
one house committee a House panel voted
to hold Attorney General William Bar and
commerce secretary Wilbur Ross in
contempt of Congress over the
administration's efforts to shield
documents related to its decision to add
a citizenship questions in the 2020
census now you may be asking yourself
what's so wrong with asking people if
they're citizens in the census
I thought the census was all about
finding out who's in the country you're
right that is what the census is
designed to do but Democrats are really
angry about this and you should ask
yourself why are Democrats so upset
about all of this why are Democrats so
upset about the asking about illegal
immigration in the country asking people
their citizenship status so they've
filed a federal case I kid you not with
the Supreme Court trying to suggest that
if illegal immigrants don't want to
answer those questions and if associated
Hispanic folks in districts with lots of
illegal immigrants decide not to answer
census workers questions then the census
cannot properly be done and thus we
ought not to ask the question which is
ridiculous I mean I'm sorry that is a
ridiculous contention that is akin to
saying that if you ask if census workers
ask about your career your job which
they do if they ask about your career
and you are offended by those questions
and are less likely to answer the Census
Bureau question well that means that the
census should be barred from asking the
question in the first place
the question is what's the real
rationale here the Democrats have
exposed why exactly they love illegal
immigration so much and I really am
puzzled at the contention by Democrats
they want to stop illegal immigration
when they refuse to fund basic services
at the border like enough beds to
provide for people seeking asylum
and the reason they don't want to do
that is because they want those people
not held at the border but released into
the interior of the United States all of
this could be solved with a simple act
of Congress Democrats do not want to
pass that act of Congress because they
have an actual interest in ensuring that
illegal immigrants enter the country now
you're asking yourself you know those
illegal immigrants they're not going to
be able to vote so why would Democrats
want them in the country why is that
something that is important to Democrats
and this Census Bureau controversy
really answers the question so the
Census Bureau controversy is based on
Democrats being very very upset that
there is a memo that was in a dead guys
computer okay and what this memo
basically suggested is that the Census
Bureau should ask these questions
because it would lead to redistricting
that there should be a push in the
United States to allocate districts
based not on the sheer population in a
district but based on the voting
population in a district in other words
if you have 800,000 illegal immigrants
in a particular district and 200,000
voting citizens then that should not be
treated the same as a district with 1
million voting American citizens which
makes sense we live in a country one man
one vote right if I am not subject to
America's laws then why exactly should I
be represented in Congress especially
when I can't vote for the people in
Congress it's bizarre it's a very
strange weird notion that we should
allocate districts based on people who
cannot vote are not citizens of the
United States and are actively breaking
American law but the reality is that if
we redistricted based on citizenship and
not based on sure population size
Democrats would lose something like nine
houses in the nine seats in the House of
Representatives according to data
analysis the reality is that Republicans
would pick up a bunch of seats because
again there are a lot of illegal
immigrants in the country and they are
all living in areas that have a lot of
Democrats not all of them a huge number
are living in areas that I mean
California is the number one source of
people who are illegal immigrants living
in the United States so if you wanted to
let's say you're a Democrat and let's
say that you wanted to insure that you
had a lot of Democratic seats in the
house but you didn't want to really add
more voters or you didn't see the need
to add more voters so what would you do
you might create maybe a sanctuary City
and maybe what you would do is you would
welcome in millions of illegal
immigrants to your city knowing that
with every illegal immigrant you were
gain
a share of a new congressional seat and
now based on the population of the
census you would be allocated more
congressional seats and now imagine
someone was going to go around asking
whether those people were illegal
immigrants for purposes of determining
how many congressional seats were
allocated well that might offend you
you might find that to be problematic
because now those congressional seats
will bleed away from the areas that you
have created that are heavy on illegal
immigrants and low on voters this is all
very telling the fact that Democrats are
opposed to a basic question like are you
in the country legally is pretty
astonishing it's pretty amazing
honestly and it is extraordinarily
telling it's extraordinarily telling the
Democrats are making this case American
Civil Liberties Union lawyer Dale Howe
wrote in a request to the Supreme Court
even in appearance that the government
has manipulated the census for partisan
and racially discriminatory purposes
would undermine public confidence in our
representative democracy well you know
what undermines my confidence in our
representative democracy when there are
a bunch of people who are being
represented who aren't voters or subject
to American law it turns out that that
really undermines my faith in
representative democracy if I and a
bunch of my fellow citizens can vote and
we are being represented with exactly
the same number of Representatives as a
bunch of people who come in the country
cannot pay taxes and cannot vote I feel
like that's a little weird and a little
bit of a problem in fact it feels like
I'm being governed by a group of folks
who are actually a political minority in
many areas the Justice Department in the
Oversight Committee are essentially on
the same trajectory as the department
and the House Judiciary Committee were
on last month the Judiciary Committee
voted to hold attorney general Barr and
contempt for failing to turn over
materials related to Robert Muller's
probe in that case the Judiciary
Committee and the Justice Department
worked out a compromise
basically the Democrats are very very
upset that they believe that there will
be political ramifications to the change
in the census question and they're
particularly upset about it because
again if there are changes in the census
question it could have some serious
impact on how many Democrats end up in
Congress they are giving credence to
every complaints about Democrats not
caring about illegal immigration and
actively seeking the illegal immigration
right now they think that they're making
a case against evil Republican racism
what they're actually making a case
against is themselves president
is not wrong when he says the Democrats
with their subpoenas they're out of
control
that they are basically just lashing out
at everyone on earth in an attempt to
avoid all of the all of the
ramifications of their own bad policy
okay in just a second we're gonna get to
President Trump and we're gonna get to
Bernie Sanders who's dropping like a
stone in the polls all it took
apparently was another quote-unquote
Democratic Socialist to rise for Bernie
Sanders to fall well gets her all that
in just a second first let me tell you
something ma'am listen I have a great
life but my life is filled with stress
and that means sometimes I struggle to
sleep I'm not alone one in three
American adults doesn't get enough sleep
if you're not sleeping enough it can
affect your cognitive function during
the day learning problem solving
decision making lack of sleep actually
leads to loss of IQ points believe it or
not that's why we are partnering with
calm the number one app for sleep sleep
deficiency does serious damage not just
to your brain but to your body as well I
mean I personally have the body of a
Greek god but if I don't sleep for like
three nights I look like the Michelin
Man the sleepless are more prone to
accidents weight gain depression with
calm you'll discover a whole library of
programs designed to help you get to
sleep your brain and body needs like
soundscapes over 100 sleep stories
narrated by soothing voices like Jerome
Flynn from Game of Thrones and Stephen
Fry right now Ben Shapiro listeners get
25% off a comb premium subscription at
calm calm / Ben that CA LM calm / Ben
they also have sleep listening programs
for like little kids so your kids won't
go to sleep knock them out with calm
calm
seriously forty million people have
downloaded calm find out why at calm
calm / man that's CA LM calm / Ben go
check them out right now
okay so meanwhile president Trump is is
in trouble again today he is in trouble
again because somebody on his comms team
decided you know what be smart let's put
him in front of George Stephanopoulos at
ABC News how could this one go wrong
okay comms team what are you doing why
would you do this who do you think you
are winning over when you put Trump in a
room with George Stephanopoulos hey
George Stephanopoulos is a Clinton ista
hack not only is he a Clinton East a
hack he obviously took talking points
manufactured by the DNC in 2012 to lead
the war on women charge against Mitt
Romney hey so now you're putting him in
a room with President Trump I can't
imagine how this would go wrong that in
and of itself is a problem
then you have the problem of President
Trump perhaps the most stubborn man ever
to live doubling down on his worst
impulses so I am NOT a fan to put it
mildly of the notion that when President
Trump was approached by a foreign
government namely the Russian government
and given xored on Hillary Clinton that
he didn't call up the FBI now points out
here two things one that is not illegal
and two Hillary Clinton did do the same
thing with the Ukrainian government so
it is true that the Ukrainian government
was trying to pass dirt on President
Trump on to Hillary Clinton and Hillary
Clinton's team took it didn't say
anything about it now the Ukrainian
government is not militantly opposed to
the United States government in the same
way that Vladimir Putin is so there is a
distinction there but Hillary should
have reported that too it is also true
that the steel dossier was largely based
the steel dossier which was the basis
for a lot of the Trump Russia collusion
charges and was basically a fantage it
was a fantasy made up by a bunch of
Russian operatives basically Christopher
Steele this former British spy went over
to Russia talked with a bunch of Russian
government officials and then funneled
that information to the Hillary Clinton
campaign so while you can say the
Hillary Clinton campaign got that
information not directly from the
Russian government they got it from
Christopher Steele in effect they were
taking Russian government created Intel
that was false about Trump and then
disseminating that inside the halls of
power in Washington DC and trotting it
out to the media as well so with all of
those caveats the fact that the Trump
administration was openly approached by
members of the Russian government and
allies with the Russian government to
take dirt on Hillary Clinton and didn't
report it to the FBI was a low point in
American politics it was ugly and it was
wrong there's a difference between
illegal and wrong it is not illegal for
a foreign government to say here's some
Oppo on your opponent and you take the
Apple and you run with it that's not
illegal it would be illegal if there was
a quid pro quo but if you said okay I'm
gonna take the Oppo and later I'm gonna
give you this thing under the table
right that's bribery but Eugene VALIC
has written professor of law at UCLA he
wrote a long post at the Washington Post
probably four years ago now talking
specifically about whether it would be
illegal if a member of the government of
Turkey approached Hillary Clinton with
info about Trump for her to use that
information the answer he came up with
and I think that his legal analysis is
correct is no now with that said would
it behoove the President of the United
States to simply say if I am approached
by a foreign government with Intel about
my opponents I will talk to the
I about it yes it would particularly
because the President of the United
States you know he was not according to
the Muller report involved in the Trump
Tower meeting he was not apprised of the
Trump Tower meeting he was not in the
loop on that thing so be very easy for
him to say listen knowing won't now what
I didn't know that I was just a guy or
it was running for president I didn't
know anything I didn't know this stuff
but now I know of course I would go to
the FBI if somebody approached me on
that sort of stuff you know you live you
learn and now I wouldn't do that instead
President Trump who has never met a
thing he will not double down upon he's
asked about this and here was his
response your campaign this time they're
added foreigners if Russia if China if
someone else offers you information on
opponent should they accept it or should
they call the FBI I think maybe you do
both I think you might want to listen I
don't there's nothing wrong with
listening if somebody called from a
country Norway we have information on
your opponent oh I think I'd want to
hear you want that kind of interference
in our elections it's not an
interference they have information I
think I'd take it if I thought there was
something wrong I'd go maybe to the FBI
okay and then he continued by saying
well maybe he wouldn't go to the FBI
because no one really wants to go to the
FBI you know again what he says on a
legal level is basically correct but on
a on a moral level it is not obviously
correct and not only is it not obviously
correct on a political level it is very
wrong right on a political level you're
running for president you've been in
meshed in this hole you're colluding
with Russia thing for four years at this
point when you just say no wouldn't you
just say no like I wouldn't take the
information and also I would pass that
along to the FBI wouldn't you just say
that it's a weird thing to say
now William bard the Attorney General
was asked about exactly the subject
about a month and a half ago by by Chris
Coons the the senator from Connecticut
Delaware from Delaware and Chris Coons
asked Barr about whether you should
report it to the FBI if somebody
approaches you with information and here
was William Barr the Attorney General's
answer what if a foreign adversary let's
now say North Korea offers a
presidential candidate dirt on a
competitor in 2020 do you agree with me
the campaign should immediately contact
the FBI
if a foreign intelligence server
intelligence or a representative of
foreign governments as we have dirt on
your opponent should they say I love it
let's meet in contact the FBI on
intelligence service does yes
okay so Barr makes a distinction there
on a legal basis between a foreign
intelligence service and a foreign
government Kunz basically broadens it
out to a foreign government and people
are saying that's Barr giving wiggle
room to Trump and there's two questions
here the legal in the moral I'm the
legal side Trump ain't wrong on the
moral side it is a very dicey
proposition at best to be taking
information from America's enemies just
because they happen to be giving you
information about your political
opponent I find it disgusting I find it
wrong and if Hillary Clinton said it
people on the right would be yelling and
screaming about it if Elizabeth Warren
does that if she gets information from
the Chinese government directed against
President Trump it just goes ahead and
uses it people are gonna be pissed and
people gonna have a right to be pissed
so that is wrong president and we'll get
to his response to all of this in just
one second first let's talk about
racking up credit card debt so I know
people who have basically ruined their
lives with credit card debt I know folks
who've racked up thousands of dollars in
charges they were told by it now pay for
it later with interest and then that
interest rate just gets wildly out of
control and I pay like 20% interest
every month and suddenly your life is
ruined don't do it instead with Lending
Club you can consolidate that debt or
pay off credit cards with one fixed
monthly payment since 2007
Lending Club has helped millions of
people regain control of their finances
with affordable fixed-rate personal
loans no trips to a bank no high
interest credit cards just go to Lending
Club com tell them about yourself how
much you want to borrow pick the terms
that are right for you if you're
approved your loan is automatically
deposited into your bank account in as
little as a few days Lending Club is the
number one peer-to-peer lending platform
with over thirty five billion dollars in
loans issued go to Lending Club comm /
Bend check their rate in minutes borrow
up to 40 grand
that's Lending Club com / Ben Lending
Club comm / Ben all loans made by web
bank member FDIC Equal Housing lender
you really can ruin your life if you
just rack up that debt and you don't do
anything about it instead go consolidate
those loans
check your rate in minutes borrow up to
40 grand that's Lending Club com / Ben
get your life back under control with
Lending Club okay in just one second
we're gonna get to president Trump's
response to himself we will also get to
Bernie Sanders dropping like a stone in
the polls we will get to Mike Pence
being rip
up and down for the basic stance that
only the American fly should flag should
fly outside the American Embassy which I
don't know why that's controversial we
get to all that in just one second first
you have to go and subscribe over at
daily wire comm when you do you not only
get the rest of today's show live on
video you also get two additional hours
I mean we are working hard to bring you
that two additional hours in the
afternoon you also get to ask us
questions in the mailbag which we'll be
doing tomorrow you also sometimes get to
interact with me during the breaks on
the radio show that we do later today
you get to be part of the mailbag when
we do the daily we're backstage we have
all sorts of goodies the Sunday special
which comes out on Saturday for you if
you are in fact a daily water subscriber
so all sorts of wonderful things coming
for you and if you get the annual
subscription you get this the very
greatest in all beverage vessels the
leftist here is hot or cold tumbler cast
her eyes upon it and despair that you
have it not but you could have it it's
like the holy grail of political
tumblers all you have to do is spend 99
bucks a year which is cheaper than the
monthly subscription Father's Day is
coming up it makes a great Father's Day
gift go check it out right now and again
I'm making this appeal for week someone
to continue making this appeal if you
love the show if you love conservative
material you need to help out the people
who produce that material in a direct
fashion yes absolutely patronize our
advertisers it really does help us but
also subscribe directly at say Lee Weyer
comm because the fact is the left is
militantly attempting to take everything
conservative off the arity platforming
people from big tech trying to attack
our advertisers you shield us from the
nastiness of the ill motivated left when
you subscribe at places like Daily wire
so please go subscribe daily where $9.99
a month or $99 a year we really
appreciate it we're the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
you
okay so in response to the hubbub
created by his comment President Trump
has now gone on a Twitter spate
this morning Ivanka please take away his
phone he tweeted out unrelated to Russia
Russia Russia although the radical left
doesn't use the name Russia anymore
since the issuance of the mullah report
House Committee now plays a seldom-used
contempt card on our great AG and
Secretary of Commerce this time on the
census Dems play a much tougher game
than the Republicans did when they had
the house majority Republicans will
remember this has already been argued
before the US Supreme Court but the
house doesn't want to wait this is a
common thread between all of the
committee's do whatever you can to
embarrass the Trump administration
attacked the Trump administration
attorney David Bruno so true in the
meantime they're getting no work done on
drug pricing infrastructure and many
other things all of that is fine then he
gets to this I meet him talked to
foreign governments every day I just met
with the Queen of England UK the Prince
of Wales he spelled it originally WH ALS
so it's good to know that the president
is familiar with Aquaman you know if we
are seriously worried about global
warming and the recession of the tides
knowing Aquaman could come in super
useful later of course the President did
correct the spelling of the Prince of
Wales but not before it became a meme
the Prime Minister of the United Kingdom
the PM of Ireland the president of
France the President of Poland we talked
about everything should I immediately
call the FBI about these causing
meetings how ridiculous I would never be
trusted again but that being said my
full answer is rarely paid by the fake
news media they purposely leave out the
part that matters yeah well I don't
think these are quite the same thing I
mean you're having a conversation with
the Prince of Wales about quote unquote
everything not the same thing as the
Russian government approaching you with
Intel about your political opponents and
when people say you know who would
actually turn over Intel about their
political opponents well back in 2000
the al gore team actually got a hold of
george w bush's debate prep book and
they turned it over to the FBI so you
know it actually does happen it actually
does happen I will say that that
President Trump I think that keeping him
away from the reporters at this point
would probably be a good idea although I
will admit this is very funny yesterday
he was in the Rose Garden I think and he
was talking to reporters and he was
trying to call on somebody and it went
like this
let's see
like nobody that's here that is indeed
very funny I mean meanwhile on the
Democratic side of the aisle Bernie
Sanders is dropping like a stone and he
is he is going down like the Soviet
economy circa 1987 it's pretty
incredible
Bernie Sanders is now dropping behind
Elizabeth Warren in virtually all state
polls he's behind Elizabeth Warren in a
Nevada state poll he is now running
behind Elizabeth Warren in a California
UC Berkeley LA Times poll
it shows Joe Biden at 22% with Elizabeth
Warren at 18%
Bernie Sanders at 17 and Kamala Harris
at 13 Carla Harris lest you forget is
the actual senator from the state of
California her running fourth that is
really bad news for common law Harris
but Sanders continues to drop in the
RealClearPolitics
polling average and that is very very
bad news for him and so Bernie has to
sort of reinvigorate his campaign the
problem is everybody's already heard
Bernie's pitch they're looking for
something new something different
somebody's got a plan they're looking
for fake Native American Elizabeth
Warren or something so Bernie gives a
big speech yesterday in which she talks
about democratic socialism and his pitch
is going to be that he is the truest
defender of democratic socialism now
recall for most of his career Bernie was
an actual supporter of communists hey
not just Norway and Denmark which are
not in fact socialist countries they're
capitalist countries with a heavy
welfare state not the same thing
democratic socialism is simply a way of
shoehorning the term socialism into a
system that has really driven in terms
of prosperity by free markets but Bernie
Sanders flanked by 1 million American
flags was speaking I mean I guess it
beats flying the Soviet flag he was more
comfortable there in 88 but now he's
running for president he did a whole
speech in which he talked about
democratic socialism he said democratic
socialism was the path of justice and
love because when I think justice and
love I think an octogenarian loon bag
who spends all of his days determining
how many types of deodorant you should
be able to buy here's Bernie Sanders
making his case my very strong belief
that the United States must reject that
path of hatred and divisiveness and
instead find the moral conviction to
choose
different paths a higher path a path of
compassion justice and love and that is
the path that I call democratic
socialism
yay justice and love and putting many
money pieces and three beach houses that
is the path and I'm a millionaire
because I wrote the books leave me alone
democratic socialism or I control
everything and call it justice and
wealth it ain't justice and it ain't
love when you're controlling other
people's lives if you love something set
it free Bernie Sanders like the economy
or other humans Bernie also suggested
that his goal here is to carry the
business of the New Deal to completion
this should give the lie to you know
Henry Olson is a columnist over at the
Washington Post he's sort of a trump
supporting columnist over at the
Washington Post we talked I think a
couple of podcasts ago about a piece
that he wrote in which he explicitly
suggested that the job of conservatives
was to prune the garden planted by FDR
which is to me an insane contention
FDR's garden was a bunch of crap okay
FDR's Garden led to a second Great
Depression from 1936 all the way up to
the outbreak of World War two FDR's
garden has led to the bankruptcy of the
American government it has led to a 20
trillion dollar deficit mainly created
by programs that he initiated like
Social Security and Bernie Sanders is
making the same cases Henry Olsen that
not that's not great for Henry Olsen
here's Bernie Sanders saying that he
wants to carry the business of the New
Deal to completion for folks who have
never studied the New Deal it is rare to
find a more fascistic take on American
economics than the than the New Deal I
mean the New Deal literally had
something called the National Recovery
administration where the government
would hand out blue eagles blue
patriotic eagles to firms that pledge to
support FDR's particular brand of
economics it's ugly stuff here's Bernie
Sanders talking about how the New Deal
must be fulfilled so we can have I
assume another Great Depression that'd
be great over 80 years ago Franklin
Delano Roosevelt helped create a
government that made transformative
progress in protecting the needs of
working families today in the second
decade of the 21st century we must take
up the on
business of the New Deal and carry it to
completion okay so you know we're gonna
carry that if you want to carry the
business of the New Deal to completion
and you know good good news he's gonna
make he's not gonna make America great
again he's gonna make the Great
Depression great again so that's
exciting stuff so that is Bernie's pitch
meanwhile Joe Biden who's trying to
separate himself off from Bernie Sanders
right supposedly Bernie Sanders is on
the left wing of the party and Choa
Biden is in the mainstream of the party
these two these two wings are merging
and this is a the problem for Joe Biden
so Joe Biden wants to run his old Joe
old reliable Joe and Joe Lincoln a
scarier he's not gonna scare you're he's
just in the grand American tradition
well Biden was asked yesterday about
whether he was on the same page as
Bernie Sanders and he was like well yeah
of course I am okay so I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna go after Bernie he's sincere
we're all on the same page guys okay Joe
Biden's on the same page as Bernie
Sanders why should he be President
really what's his pitch exactly wonder
why Elizabeth Warren is rising it's
because Joe Biden can't explain why he
wants to be president and Bernie Sanders
seems even kookier than Elizabeth Warren
Joe Biden's pitch by the way is not a
particularly attractive pitch he says
that his first move as president of the
United States will be to raise your
taxes this is from the so-called
moderate
for multi millionaires and billionaires
guess what it's gone guys when I'm
president your tax cuts they're gone now
he tells a lie right there in open an
obvious lie the lie being that it's
mostly for millionaires and billionaires
okay I can express to you as a person
who makes a lot of money in the state of
California
I got destroyed on taxes last year if
the Trump tax cut actually destroyed
everyone who's a higher earner in
liberal-leaning states with high tax
rates the fact is 80% of Americans saw a
tax cut and the vast majority of those
people are not in the top 1% or in the
top 10% but Joe Biden is gonna raise
your taxes it's a bold move cotton we'll
see how it goes for him also Joe Biden's
pitch is that for eight years there was
no hint of a scandal or lie in the Obama
administration well see how this one
goes over - it's um it's fascinating how
Biden has really avoided talking about
the Obama administration when he does
it's in these very broad terms about how
great things were under Barack Obama
weren't they just awesome sure we won't
talk about the incredibly slow economic
recovery or the fact that the Obama
administration set the middle-east on
fire sure we're not going to talk about
the fact that it was an incredibly
polarizing administration on both
politics and culture we want to talk
about any of those things no it was it
was just it was wonderful it was
basically utopia don't you remember like
five years ago as youto riots in
Ferguson and it was utopia guys stop
that utopia according to Joe Biden was
really not a hint any hint I wrote a
whole book about the various scandals of
the Obama administration you can go
check it out it's called the People vs
Barack Obama it's a whole book and that
the good news for Joe Biden and many
other Democrats is that as long as you
have acolytes like Joy Behar you'll be
fine so Joy Behar over on the view made
what I think is one of the dumbest
comments I have ever heard so Joe Biden
has been going around proclaiming that
if he is elected president he will do a
couple of things will raise your taxes
and also have little cure cancer not
sure how he's gonna do that second thing
I guess Joe Biden so Joe Biden's plan
goes something like this
elect me president question mark cancer
cured that's that's the plan I hope you
enjoyed but joy behar is already making
excuses for why Joe Biden may not act
be able to cure cancer those excuses do
not include that it's very hard to cure
cancer since cancer is in fact a bucket
of different things it doesn't include
the fact that we've been trying to cure
cancer for decades and we have been some
progress but not tremendous progress
something acute Klute the real problem
according to Joy Behar is that if Joe
Biden becomes president and wants to
cure cancer it may be too late because
of flips through dec global warming
that's it really this is a thing a human
said curing cancer is going to be much
more difficult when there's so much
climate change and pollutants in the
environment because a lot of cancer is
environmentally caused and this
president rolls back anything that will
clean the air I just don't like are they
working against each other if they don't
also clean up the emission ok so what
now that does you understand how cures
work like if you cure tuberculosis then
you've cured the disease if you are
curing cancer then presumably you are
curing the disease that is cancer and
even if it's caused you know have a cure
but that's also global warming doesn't
have to global warming doesn't cause
cancer if you're talking about emissions
that cause cancer then you would be
talking about you know pollutants in the
air like somebody is is spewing ash into
the air and this causes lung cancer or
something man when you have people
making excuses like that put her on the
stump man she's she's fantastic
and meanwhile the Democrats are growing
more and more nasty and radical by the
day on social issues you know I remember
a time when the case for the gay rights
movement was basically leave us alone so
that we could do what we want and
everybody was kind of like ok sure make
sense and then it was ok well we want
the same government benefits as married
couples and people like well not so sure
about that one since married couples
heterosexual married couples actually
you know are in the business of
producing children and then heterosexual
marriage is really about the production
and rearing of children so there are
different societal benefits to that than
just two people who love each other
living together but I guess ok and then
they were like what we don't want a
marriage but now we won't get marriage
so if you can just call it marriage then
we'll be cool we'll never bother you
again and everybody was like well you
know not so hot on this one but maybe if
the government stays out of the business
of marriage maybe if you sort of leave
us alone I will learn to live with it
alright I guess and then
now the new pushes we need to fly the
gay pride flag above the US Embassy
where did what now so your pitch is that
something that your original case was
leave us alone so we can engage in the
private consensual behavior we like that
went to we need you to celebrate that
private consensual behavior on a flag on
the top of the United States Embassy in
like Botswana what in the actual F what
in the world
so Mike Pence was asked about this the
vice president because he put out an
edict basically or he was asked to
defend an edict put out by the Trump
administration that at the US Embassy we
should fly the wait for it the US flag I
know crazy idea right like cuz it's the
United States so the flag we should fly
it shouldn't be like the gay pride flag
or like a Christian flag or a Planned
Parenthood flag it should probably just
be like he'd the United States flag so
Pence was asked about this and here's
what he said did the administration
direct US embassies not to fly the pride
flag I'm aware that the State Department
indicated that on the flag pole of our
American embassies that one flag should
fly and that's the American flag and I
support that to the LGBTQ community who
feels as though that runs counter to the
president celebrating Pride Month in his
tweet when it comes to the American flag
pole at American embassies and capitals
around the world having the one American
flag fly I think is the right decision
why is this remotely controversial why
I'm so confused but Sarah Silverman
found it controversial so I can't do a
Sarah Silverman voice because no one
actually has a voice that high her whole
shtick is to do this cutesy voice and
then curse
so you said dear VP you're a
hate-mongering fear-based weasel and
your biggest irony is that if there was
hell you'd 100% be going there I'm not
sure
like Sarah McLaughlin if she knows what
irony means she's I hope you go to
prison for crimes against humanity
regarding the LGBT community
remember this started with private
consensual behavior should be left alone
by the government and now it's you
should go to prison if you don't want to
fly a gay pride flag at the US Embassy
that's where we have come to guys I'm
pretty sure that the fascists are not
the Conservatives here
she's women's rights and the babies you
ripped from the arms of parents seeking
our help what did the light Sarah
Silverman is so we have now reached the
point where I think frankly that we
should remove the American flag patches
from American soldiers shoulders and
now when they go into battle against
like the Taliban they should wear it's
gay pride month I should wear a gay
pride flag they should know what they're
fighting for and then when it's Breast
Cancer Awareness Month issue were a
breast cancer awareness flag so that
when a Taliban soldiers getting his
brains shot out he should know that we
here in the United States we hate breast
cancer and we will fight breast cancer
with every last vestige of our strength
and ability yes the country may be too
stupid for repair all right time for
some things I like and then some things
that I hate so things that I like
douglas Carswell was one of the leaders
of the brexit movement he has a brand
new book that is coming out I believe
you can already buy it called progress
versus parasites we'll have him on the
show next month probably to talk about
it
at least the radio show the book is
really good it's called progress versus
parasites a brief history of the
conflict that shaped our world that
covers an enormous amount of ground it
really does talk about why it is that
certain areas of the world thrive in
other areas of the world do not his
basic thesis is that when you have a
Mandarin class when you have a group of
people who sit atop a government who are
taking all of the gains of a particular
of a particular country and centralizing
it in that body for either
redistribution or for political purposes
it ends up sapping the will and sapping
the Entrepreneurship inside that society
and he traces that pattern throughout
history not just sticking to the West
but moving around the world the book is
a really good kind of fun historical
read go check it out douglas Carswell
progress versus parasites you can go get
that at Amazon right now ok time for a
quick thing that I hate all right so the
thing that I hate today so Bill Maher he
has crafted this this weird sort of
conspiracy theory so I was on Mars show
last year and Maher asked me about the
Russia collusion stuff and I said listen
if you prove that Trump colluded with
Russia
meaning if you prove that Trump was in a
conspiracy with Russia to thwart our
elections then impeachment should be on
the table I said that tomorrow I said I
don't see any evidence of that now and I
don't think any evidence of that is
going to actually come forward I was
right no Bill Maher has moved on to
another conspiracy theory Beck he said
he couldn't believe it he said you don't
believe that Trump colluded with Russia
and I was like no because I don't see
the evidence of it if you show me the
evidence then maybe and Bill Maher was
like I can't believe that you don't
believe that another world otherwise
smart person like Bill Maher was on CNN
with I believe
Chris Cuomo here and he says if his news
his new theory is that if President
Trump is defeated in 2020 he won't go
like like that woman from like Jennifer
Hudson from Dreamgirls he will just
stick around he's telling you he's not
going to see here's bill maher
explaining his new conspiracy theory
which is that Trump is going to I guess
wedge himself into the Oval Office with
super glue and then dare people to carry
him out if he loses Trump he won't go
I've been saying that since before he
got elected that if he loses the second
time I'm if he loses the coming election
he and Michael Cohen said that that's he
Pelosi echoed said that a lot of people
say well yes it can happen here meaning
fascism meaning something other than
what we was democracy now I think we're
already there you know I have a dictator
checklist that I read on my show
sometimes things that know a pret
merican president has ever done but this
president does this is Banana Republic
so you think he wouldn't leave that is
one of them I absolutely think he will
not leave oh so what will he do does he
think the US military is just in a
station itself around the White House to
prevent him from leaving
is that what Bill Maher thanks this is
such conspiratorial tripe it's so funny
all the same people who are claiming
that Donald Trump will not leave if he
loses an election are still claiming
that stacey abrams is the legitimate
governor of georgia all of them so all
right I mean if this is this is where if
you're so far gone that your new shtick
is that Donald Trump will not be ejected
from the Oval Office that what he'll set
up like squatters rights in the Oval
Office if he if he's not elected in 2020
oh my goodness creating phantom Trump in
your mind is what's going to lead to his
election victory if he wins truly
they've hit the idea that Trump is
Hitler he's the worst person who ever
lived he's a dictator most Americans
look at that who have a brain and they
say well I'm not really seeing that so
much UK you can oversell here and I
think that the Democrats and many in the
media are overselling already we'll be
back here later today with two
additional hours of programming so we
will see you then I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam Savitz audio is mixed by
Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup is by
Jesuit alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily weiter
2019 president Trump makes a big foreign
policy faux pas as shells hit oil
tankers in the Gulf of Oman and hundreds
of thousands of people take to the
streets to protest in Hong Kong then
Jordan B Peterson has a new social media
platform for free speech and deep fake
videos threatened to upend the twenty20
election and reality check it out on the
Michael Nolt show